Hello, everybody.
Oh my god, starting off the fucking stream strong.
Hello, hello.
Oh my god.
Okay, I do sound a lot better.
I'm still coughing.
Bad news, I was not able to go to the hospital for the antibiotics because...
I sort of slept the whole day.
I have no excuse.
I legitimately was so tired after the back-to-back tournament that I just slept the whole day.
Like, no other excuses.
I was just extremely exhausted.
So, yeah.
Also, I heated my leftovers for dinner, so I might be munching on some leftovers from last night.
Do I sound better?
I sound a lot better.
Guys, no, you don't understand.
I literally spent the last two days just sleeping.
The first break day on Monday, I was just so tired.
I just slept most of the day.
And then...
Okay, you guys might have seen it because people already posted clips of it.
And I played Marvel Rivals late at night because I have a problem.
And we all know that I have a problem.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're your own worst enemy sometimes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, there is a clip of Nekros as Spider-Man pulling me off the cliff from fucking Narnia.
And it was not a good day for me.
That was not...
And then, because of that, I Tilt-Q'd.
Well, not because of what he did.
But also, I was having some very fucking terrible rank...
I was having a very terrible rank grind.
How terrible, you might ask?
I'm down 150 points.
That's how terrible it was.
It was not a good day.
And because I was so depressed over that, next day...
I just slept the whole day yesterday as well.
I...
I slept...
Okay, not 150.
It was like 120.
I'll say 120 points.
It was more like 120 points in one session.
In one rank session.
It was just...
It was not a great day.
And then, the second day, I was very sad.
Not because of Marvel Rivals.
And tired.
Okay, it wasn't because I was just depressed because of Marvel Rivals.
I was still very, very tired.
So, yesterday, I spent the entire day also sleeping.
And...
And just like...
I just fucking hibernated the entire time.
I legitimately...
I got into my morning meeting.
My morning meeting with my manager.
Just to be like...
Okay, these are the things I have to do.
And shit like that.
And also, let me know if the BGM is loud enough.
Just to be like...
These are the things I have to do.
And I was like...
Alright.
And then, my manager was like...
Okay, so...
So, like...
After that...
You're gonna work on this, right?
You're gonna go to the hospital.
Bring your laptop and work on this.
And I was like, yeah.
And then, after the call was over...
I...
Went to bed.
And just slept.
I just...
I just went to bed and just...
Bye.
I'm gone.
I'm fucking gone.
And I woke up.
I woke up.
3 in the morning.
And then, I was just like...
Alright.
Well, I woke up earlier to grab something to eat.
Because I was like...
I should at least get some food in my system.
And after eating, I spent a little bit of time on the PC.
And then, I didn't play my revivals yesterday.
Because I was still depressed over losing 120 points.
I was still depressed.
And...
I just literally just...
Did my stuff.
Walked...
Yogi Amber Doge.
At like...
3 in the morning.
And then, slept again.
And then, slept all the way till today.
And I woke up today at 12.
And I was like...
I'm just gonna be lazy.
I was a lazy day.
I felt so lazy.
After winning that tournament...
I was just not a person.
I don't know.
I think like...
Waking up at 8 AM.
All those...
Waking up at 8 AM too.
For all those hours.
Just like...
I don't know.
It fucking ruined me.
The back to back 8 AM streams.
And then, also streaming for 8 hours straight.
Playing my revivals.
It just fucked me up.
It also ruined dad's fucking feeding schedule.
Cause now he thinks he's gonna get fed at 8 AM all the time.
He wakes me up at 8 AM.
I'm so angry.
He wakes me up at 8 to 9 AM for feeding.
Because of...
Because of 2 days.
Just 2 days of fucked up schedules.
He thinks his feeding time is now 8 to 9 AM.
I'm like...
It's 2 days.
How could 2 days change your entire life?
Doki.
How?
Like, I don't understand.
So like, now he wakes me up at 8 to 9 AM.
Cause he's like...
Woo, feeding time.
And I'm like, no it's not.
But then he doesn't stop barking.
He'll be like...
It's feeding time.
And I'm like, it's 8 in the fucking morning.
Like...
He knows I can get up early.
Yes, he knows that I can get up earlier.
That's the worst part.
He fucking knows.
Because before then, he wouldn't wake me up earlier.
Cause he's like, oh, she'll never wake up this early.
But now that he knows that I can wake up that early.
He wakes me up early now.
And I'm like, no.
I'm just like, no.
And I try to like, fix him.
To go back to my old schedule.
Because I was like, I can't.
I'm not a per...
Like, I had to feed him yesterday.
At like, the last 2 days.
At like, 9 AM or some shit.
And I go back to sleep.
Because I just can't.
I legitimately will not be awake.
I'm not a person.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Won't ink this.
The consequences of my own actions.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yeah.
Also, like, I need to tell you guys this.
I don't remember if this was yesterday or the day before yesterday.
But like, while I was like, hibernating.
And like, I don't know.
Basically being dead.
While I was hibernating.
I woke up at like, 3 in the morning.
To walk him.
Because like, I need to fix his schedule too.
Because like, his walk schedule is like, so fucked up now.
Like, his walking schedule is really fucked up.
Because like, I walked him at like, 3 PM.
So then he's like, oh now, he thinks his walking hours is like, 2 to 3 AM.
So anyway.
So like, I'm trying to fix that.
So like, I'm going to be walking him earlier today to fix that schedule.
Anyway.
So.
I walked him at 3 AM today.
Not today, sorry.
One of those rest days.
And it was so fucking weird.
Because, while on the walk.
There was a phone on the ground.
And like, I was...
It was so weird.
It was so ominous.
Because I was like, why is there a fucking random phone just lying on the ground.
On the sidewalk.
Because I was like, that's weird.
I've never...
And then the next...
The morning, when I did his morning walk.
It was gone.
So like, I was like, why is there this random...
I took a picture of it too.
Because I was so confused.
I was like, this is not right.
I was like, why is this here?
Like, I was so confused.
I was like, this ain't right.
Why is...
So look, look, look.
I found this random phone on the sidewalk.
Because I was like...
I didn't pick it up.
I took a picture of it.
But it was 3 in the morning.
It was 3 in the morning.
I was like, I took a picture of it.
Because I was so...
I thought it was weird.
Yeah, a random flip phone.
Yeah, I was like, did a crime happen?
Like...
Was there some sort of like, deal that happened in the middle of the night?
Like, I...
Like...
Yeah.
I...
I didn't pick it up.
Because I knew...
I knew that's weird.
I...
I knew if I picked it up...
I might be like, inflicted in some fucking crime.
Like...
So like, I didn't want to get my fingerprints on it.
But I did take a picture of it.
I took a picture.
Because I was like, that's weird.
Anyway...
The next...
The morning of...
Like, obviously, you know, because he needs his morning walks.
Like, the phone was gone.
It was gone.
Like...
Like, I was just...
I was like, why is this here at 3 in the morning?
And it was like, in the middle of the sidewalk too.
Like, I...
I don't know.
I almost picked it up.
I...
I was so close to picking this up.
I almost did.
I was just like, oh my god.
Like, what is this doing there?
Like...
I didn't.
Okay?
I didn't listen to my...
I didn't listen to the thoughts in my head.
No, it was gone.
Someone picked it up.
I don't know who.
But someone picked it up in the morning.
Like...
No, there is chat.
It's just the burner phone is covering it.
Oh wait, there is no chat.
What the fuck?
I thought I fixed it.
You're right.
There was no chat.
Where is it?
Okay, there it is.
Yeah, so like...
That's basically...
What happened.
During...
It was not very exciting last couple of days though.
NotSoDeadphone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That phone was a miserable story quest.
You're gonna have to try again on a new game.
Bless.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, you don't train dad at this point.
He trains you.
I know.
He's basically...
He's doing his best.
Doing his absolute best.
Liz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Octopic, good news Doki.
I found the plus.
FYI, information for you because I only won one prize.
So don't give me the Torobo box.
So I can't exactly prove I won from there.
But shipping to you soon.
It's alright.
As long as we have our super buff bear plush.
I'll be happy.
Thank you for the super chat, Liz.
Thank you, thank you.
Also...
I'll take this time...
To show you guys an update.
So...
What I'm going to be showing you is actually from...
Parts from the charity outfit auction.
So you guys remember...
There was a charity auction for an outfit that was decided by the winner of the auction.
They also picked expressions.
So, I was getting my expressions updated on my skin suit.
Not this one.
But the one that's being rigged at the moment.
So, they added some of the expressions that the winner requested onto me.
So, I'll show you guys the update.
Woah!
Woah, skin suit update.
I can't change my hair color or anything.
Or like my hair or whatever.
Like what Mint did.
But I have new faces I can make.
And other than...
Okay, so this one, we requested this.
We requested this before.
Which was done a long time ago.
But like, I procrastinated.
So...
After my Marvel rivals...
Guys...
Just one more game, guys.
Just...
Just one more game.
I swear to God.
Guys...
Just one more game.
I swear to God.
Last game.
LG.
This is LG, guys.
I just need two wins.
Okay, two LGs.
I just need two wins, guys.
Please.
Okay.
Anyway.
The next three are actually from the auction winner.
So, you can thank her for these pics.
So...
Oh, wait.
This is actually...
No, this is bonus.
So, this is just me blushing a little.
My whole teehee.
So, it's just like more of a blush.
Right here.
But then...
But then, these two were requested.
The doom and gloom.
Please, guys.
It'll be over soon.
Oh, yeah.
Me looking for it.
I was like, where's the map?
Where is it?
Oh, so...
Okay.
So, this one.
You fucking freak.
Oh,
my God.
So, this was the requested one.
Alright.
I'll fucking take you that off, though.
Yes.
Also, I'm calling the personnel.
For those who wanna know who won this particular...
Who won this particular auction to have all of that.
It is...
You have to thank Nexty for that.
So, yeah.
That was...
This was...
This specifically was also Nexty's...
That would make sense in context.
So, you gotta thank her for adding that expression.
Thank you for the super chat, Nexty.
Thank you.
So, yes.
I have new updates.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're so winning.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But honestly, my favorite one so far was...
What context is it?
True.
Here's my favorite one.
This one is...
This is how I feel everyday.
Jesus.
Whoa, Jesus.
For you, Jesus.
I'll do it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Damn, Jesus.
Oh,
my God.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
Somebody's going to hell and it ain't me.
Rest in peace.
No, I like...
Calm down, Jesus.
So, yeah.
So, those are the updates for me today.
I have no idea what the schedule is going to be like for this week.
I am taking it so much more chill.
Because...
I don't know.
The last two days...
Who is this canary?
Lay off the bath salts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Fuck it.
Thank you.
Yeah, Jesus being a little freaky right now.
But, yes.
This week, I have no idea.
Because, like...
I have been super lazy the last two days.
I don't know why.
The Vtuber Rivals thing really threw me off.
Because, it was so intense.
It was just such an intense tournament.
Like, apparently, it was like...
It was 130 teams.
And, it was such an intense tournament.
That, like...
Like, my whole body, like, just...
My whole body was just like...
I'm done.
Yeah, and it did help that...
I had to IGL for it.
So, like, you know.
I had to, like, think a lot for that tournament as well.
So...
So, like, obviously, I was like...
I was just, like, using up all my energy and everything.
Yeah.
It was intense.
It was very, very intense.
I might maybe make a...
I've edited a video of it.
Because, it was actually a really...
It was a great...
It was a great time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Jesus just needs a little assistance.
Don't you want the second coming of Jesus?
Oh my God.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
Is it fucked up?
Am I going to hell if I say, like...
Guys, would I go to hell if I say that, like...
Isn't Jesus, you know...
Isn't Jesus technically...
Okay, guys.
Guys.
I'm not religious.
But, like...
I don't know if that makes it better or not for me to say this.
Guys.
Is there a priest here where I can go to confession after?
Anyway.
Isn't he, like, sort of, you know...
A virgin?
Like...
I'm sorry.
I'm...
Oh, boy.
And...
Wow.
It's Ash Wednesday.
Doki.
Jesus was made in the list.
Yeah, I mean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Jesus.
The OG Cooner.
Thank you for the super chat.
Well, technically, you were all here for this.
So, we're all going to hell unless we all repent.
Because you...
You guys enabled me.
Because you guys were part of the problem.
So, like...
We're all going...
We're all going somewhere together.
We're all...
You watched this stream.
So, you are part of the problem.
Yeah.
You chose to say it.
Meme.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
Monkey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
DJ.
No, no.
She's got a point.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Warren.
He wishes to spread his love.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mehdi.
That's why people...
Become a wizard.
They don't pay by the time they're 30.
Thank you for the super chat, Mehdi.
Thank you.
Wait, that makes him the ultimate wizard.
Is that...
Is that true?
I thought, like...
Jesus doesn't believe in magic.
Cafe.
Thank you for your very brave super chat.
Oh, my God.
This is a topic where he's like, You know what?
You deserve my money.
After calling out Jesus as a virgin.
That's crazy.
I called him out and he's like, That's my streamer.
Right there.
CafeClown.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't think heaven was chill like that.
Guess I'll read more scripts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Heck, thank you for the Akasupa.
Repentance tax to go...
Guys, I mean...
Wait, is it fucked up if I...
Okay, what was it?
Uh...
Church...
Donation...
Oh, boy.
What is it called?
You know that little...
The little bowl they pass around?
Oh, this one.
Is it fucked up if...
Oh, I definitely am going somewhere.
That's...
That's great.
No, is it fucked up if like...
You know...
Like...
Like, if I put this out...
Here...
Like this...
And then...
Oh, wait, let me reset this.
If I put this here...
Like that, you know?
You know, like the thing that you pass around or that?
And then I...
And then I put...
Is this fucked up?
Am I going somewhere?
Am I going somewhere if I put this down here?
Am I going somewhere if I do this?
Am I...
And then...
Wait, wait, where's my...
Where's my alert?
Where is it?
Okay, so my alert's over here.
So then all I have to do...
Is move the alert right here.
If I...
If I move the alert here...
Then it'll make more sense.
AK, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Simple-minded.
Doki...
If you have to start a sentence like that, you already know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh shit, let me put this...
Oh, now it makes sense!
Guys, look at that!
Wait, this works!
Wait, this...
Doki buying a new way to get to the big downstairs.
Save a spot for us too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Wait, this works!
Guys!
I like how it's like dad's dancing on the repentance.
Dancing in the little...
The little thing.
Wait, this makes so much sense.
Does this count as a tax rate?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wolfhound, thank you for the super chat.
Putting a fake dollar bill into the donation bowl so I go to hell.
I mean, see...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This five is for the bulk.
I mean religion.
Golden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah!
Is that what they say?
The more you donate, the more heaven you get?
Yeah!
Like, remember those like...
What was it called?
Like the...
The ones that are actual scams.
This isn't a scam.
But the one where they do like the tele...
The TV relig...
The TV churches.
You know?
Where, um...
What are they called?
The...
Like, you know where they're like...
You gotta send your money to this church now.
And then...
Yeah, the televen...
The tele...
Televangelist.
I fucking can't pronounce it.
Yeah!
This is not that one.
This is like different because we're not on TV.
We're on...
It's different.
Because we're not on TV.
We're on the internet.
So this is a lot different.
Um...
Yes.
I will...
Anyway.
So you know how they're like...
It's just a call.
Jason, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
So like, you know.
They would do that.
They're like...
Oh, the more you...
You'd send your...
Send your money right now.
To like this address.
And...
And Jesus...
And God will forgive your sin.
But for me...
I'll be like...
A super chat right now.
So you can see dad dancing on the pole.
Brother, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All it took was a pole for chat to unfold.
Um...
Johnny...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Behold.
The rise of stream evangelists.
Don't you...
Stop giving them ideas.
Oh my God.
Why don't they just stream on like YouTube and Twitch for their...
Wait, what's the point?
Since we're in the new age, people don't watch TV anymore anyway.
So like...
I feel like if they...
If they're gonna keep doing this tradition...
They could do sermons on stream.
Like...
Did you guys...
I mean like...
It's such a great idea.
And then like...
They can have like super chat enable.
It'd be like...
One Akasupa equals one confession.
If you...
If you want God to forgive you...
Make sure to super chat on Akasupa.
They already do?
Oh my God.
They're so ahead of their time.
Bro, I just figured that out today.
Confession stream when...
When they actually...
I saw like a priest TikTok account.
Like an actual priest that does like...
Like TikToks and stuff.
To like raise...
Like make like...
Make...
Make religion...
Make like Christianity cool again.
To like...
Be hip with the youngins.
Angel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jesus thanks you for the bitties.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Gia.
Thank you for seeing all these during...
Wait, is it actually...
My neon DJ Wolfie?
Wait.
Is it Ash Wednesday?
Oh my God.
We're all going...
Wait.
Is it lit?
Oh, fuck.
Oh my God.
Okay.
We're all going somewhere.
We're
all going somewhere.
We're so fucked.
Zekro, thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm here to confess my sins.
I'm not washing up jokey boy.
Even on my breaks.
The vibes aren't enough.
Please allow me to repent.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Casey.
Welcome to the maid of fire.
Welcome, welcome.
I just joined.
Please don't drag me with the others.
At least it'll be warm.
True.
Um, it'll be warm though, DJ.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Emilion.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jokey, they did the forgiving sins for super chat 600 years ago.
And it led to 100 years of war in Europe because of the prison reformation.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but it hasn't happened in NA yet.
First time for everything.
You know, first time for everything, guys.
Um, Kira.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Bexa.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mormons give 10% of their income.
So have you heard of our lord and savior, Jokey Bird?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God.
Today is wild.
This is what it's like when I'm lazy today.
Um, Tia.
I feel like today, because I feel so lazy and tired, usually, I have a slight filter on, but I definitely don't have any filters right now.
I'm going all in.
If I'm- it's too late.
Now that I know I'm definitely going somewhere, nothing can stop me now.
Nothing can stop me.
I already know where I'm going.
The best I can do is just keep digging.
You got lazy and condemned us all.
Yes!
You shall all be part of the problem.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki.
Thanks for coming to OtakuFest.
Just want to share that one of the Doki cosplayers in the meet-and-greet queue gave everyone a free Doki eye-print and affordable fans.
If you're here, thank you so much.
Oh my god, I received one of them too.
So cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really- I was- it was really- I love doing them.
I love doing meet-and-greets and stuff because I like seeing like all the fan- fans coming together to celebrate like me for some reason even though like I'm literally sending all of us to hell, right?
Celebrating me right now.
I really appreciate it guys.
I really do.
Let's see, where was I?
ABI, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I believe this is now the tomato church.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The man, the stream took a very strange turn.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like- I think it's right.
I think like eventually I was heading there.
I just- I was eventually gonna head here anyway, so I just sped up the process, you know, I just- It's the eye- yeah, the eye bags make it- wait, let me- let me like make sure it's more immersive.
Give me a sec.
Let me edit this real quick.
I'm gonna make it so that it feels more immersive and everything.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm opening the file.
Oh my god.
My Photoshop is so slow right now.
All right, let me delete this real quick.
Okay, delete that.
Save.
Where is that file?
What is that file?
Was it a JPEG?
Is this a JPEG?
No, what is that file?
No, it is a JPEG.
Okay, all right.
Okay, all right, don't worry guys.
I'll make it even more immersive.
Wait, is that the right JPEG?
Whoops, it's the wrong one.
Give me a sec.
Quick export.
Whoop, I saved in the wrong area.
I saved in my thumbnails.
Give me a sec.
There we go.
I feel like I kick-started something and it was a mistake.
I'm so sorry y'all.
Also, ten more for repentance.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There we go.
Yeah, there we go.
Now, it's transparent.
Now it's transparent, guys.
It's even more immersive.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh My god, okay, so like Have you guys seen that?
Okay, did you guys know there's like really fucking weird competitions?
I was like, I found out, like I was looking through Twitter.
I found out there's a thing called plumbing competitions.
Did you guys know that?
I didn't realize plumbing competition.
There's a competition for everything.
So like there's like a tournament.
There's actually like a league for plumbers where they like basically compete on who's the best, like who's the fastest plumber.
Yeah, and I was like watching.
I was like, what the fuck?
Oh my god, there's a competition for everything.
Let me show you guys the video.
It like popped up on my, I don't know if I can, wait plumbing competition.
That's so interesting.
I watched a little bit of it.
Yeah, the 2023 National Plumbing Championship.
The national, what?
There's a national competition.
Oh my god.
Okay, let me uh, let's skip my, let me skip this ad real quick.
Oh my god, there's so many ads.
Sorry, they like, I don't know if you guys noticed, but like they like, um My favorite ad blocker got deleted.
That's okay, I didn't say it.
My favorite ad blocker got like deleted off of Chrome.
So if anyone who uses that might, uses that same ad blocker, it's gone now.
It's gone now, so like, I gotta, Which is good, cuz then you guys can give me more ad revenue, you know.
It's okay guys, that's alright.
I mean you, cuz you guys weren't using ad blockers on my stream, right guys?
And if you are, don't make me tap my repentance.
Don't make me tap the repentance side.
If you are, this is the perfect time to fucking repent right now.
If, if you were using an ad blocker on my stream, it's right here.
I would never.
Okay, alright, right in front of my channel?
Really?
Oh my god, I was like watching a little bit, it was actually pretty hardcore.
Honestly, always using premium.
It's pretty fucking hardcore.
I was like, damn, what the fuck?
Can't believe there's a competition for everything.
Christopher, thank you for your very first super chat.
Forgive me, Doki, for I have sinned.
It's been three months since I've last seen your stream.
I confess that I have cheated with other Vtubers and used ad blocker on, and your very first stream back is this?
Out of everything I streamed, this is your first stream coming back.
I'm literally, I'm not even talking about anything today.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Neppers, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
But I don't know what to do this week.
I have no like collabs, plan or anything.
I'm gonna like Friday, because I said I promised Adam that I'd like show up for his birthday.
I don't have like anything, like, actual plan for this week.
I've just been feeling incredibly, um, incredibly lazy this week.
The last two days, I've been feeling incredibly lazy.
Just cuz like, also there's some help that I've been like sick the last couple of weeks, so I've been getting better.
I don't have like, like my nose isn't stuffed up anymore, so I am getting a lot better now.
It's just my voice.
My voice is still like, like a work in progress, but it is, it is sound, I do sound a lot of better now, but Griffin, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Like, my voice sounds a lot better.
I mean, it still needs work.
It still definitely needs work, but like, I am recovering very slowly.
But I'm trying to figure out, like, I'm trying to figure out if I should go to the hospital anyway.
Um, just cuz like, just, just to be sure, just to get something to like, like fast.
Like, I don't know if it's just my voice anymore.
If I just need to make sure I don't talk as much the next week.
Also,
I should.
I'll think about it.
Most likely I might, I might.
I was just, like I said, I literally was just sleeping.
Um, I was just sleeping most of the time.
Also, I have an idea for like, a future merch.
Like, this popped up on my, this popped up on my Twitter.
I did not, I should have known because like, I, you know, we have the My Melody version of this, but I saw this.
I saw this, and I really, I really want to make...
I want to, I saw Puchako, I saw Puchako boxers, and I was like, oh my god.
I want to make, I want to make Dragoon.
No, no, I do refuse.
I will not be on the boxers, guys.
But, I thought it would be funny to have, to have Dragoon boxers.
Not, not me.
I will, I will not be on those boxers.
But, cuz like, okay, what I've noticed is that like, a lot of VTuber merch is like, very catered towards like, girls.
And I was like, oh my god, we should have boxers, like, to represent the guys, or like, girls who want to wear boxers, too.
So, or, you know, I could have the tomato on, too.
So, I thought, I thought it would be such a cool idea to have like, tomato, oh yeah, tomato, KuroKy, and Dragoon boxers in the future.
So, I like, thought about it, too.
Definitely is something in the future that I'm gonna do, where you, see guys, I know what you guys really want.
I know, I know what you guys really want.
The VTuber, the VTuber boxers, I'm here to represent.
I'm sorry to all the brief users out there.
I'm sorry.
To all the brief users out there, I'm sorry.
I'm not here to represent you.
I'm just here for the boxers.
Congo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I confess that I reversed the colors on my monitor during your stream, so that you can become green.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's too hot in Australia.
Amaru, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I bought your PJs for my girlfriend's birthday gift because I got scammed on the $100 plush I originally bought for her.
Wait, what did you get?
What $100 plush?
How did you get scammed for... Also, what the fuck kind of plushie was $100?
Holy shit.
That must be some fucking elite plushie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yogi, please, I need the tomato beanie.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Agent, thank you for the super chat.
Don't lie, you won it for yourself.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I refuse to be on the boxers, guys.
I refuse to be on the boxers.
I don't mind putting you guys on the boxers.
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, you're saying you're a boxers overrated kind of person?
I'm just saying you could put more cute stuff on you could put more cute things on a boxers versus Versus briefs because they're so like, you know, there's not enough space, you know Okay, but like have you guys ever seen like okay, so like okay.
Um, I mean look it up This is something I looked up a long time ago, and I thought it was so fucking funny.
Uh Let's see Let's say I could find it.
Okay, but like have you ever seen like apex boxers?
Have you guys ever seen like I think it's so funny because Okay, I'm just like Hey, okay guys, let's be like don't care you okay, but like you guys ever seen apex legends boxers cuz it's fucking wild Let me show you guys a picture of one of them All right,
so this is there's one with Pathfinder I thought was really fun.
Okay, so like
When you're with when you're with your significant do you think okay if you wear this on a date Do you think they'll be disappointed?
I'm Saying yeah, the positioning of this is like
If you if you wear this if you wear this at a date and then like you're like You're about to go to third base.
Do you think they'll be disappointed in you?
This is definitely Definitely intentional.
Um, we're both.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What is this topic?
I love this
Okay, wait, let me say goodbye, okay the Pathfinder one is even funnier let me say Everyone um, oh my god, you're fine it I don't remember how I got into this rebel.
I was just looking up like Looking up like I was looking I'm like dumb Oh, I think it was when I wonder what I got the my melody boxers Ocean yes, they're real they're actually real it's on it's on the alley Oh
It's not AliExpress guys, I know it's real cuz it's not AliExpress but like
How much do I love apex legends Hey, let me say goodbye.
Oh my god.
Wait, no.
Okay.
All right for those four years Valentine's gift idea guys or like birthday idea birthday gift idea Give them this That's
If you love them you Do you know anybody that loves apex legends guys you Do you know anyone that knows Apex Legends?
I bet they would appreciate this box.
Not this much.
Thank you.
Okay.
Um, yes.
Sorry.
I'm really sorry that the Minecraft server for members has been like sort of dead for a while now.
But for those who are in the member stream, you sort of know why.
Like, everything was put on a hold.
Uh, for everything.
So like, you guys sort of know why.
Like, everything was sort of like all over the place.
Um, if you're there for the member stream.
But, anyway.
Um, I think like a couple days ago, we are finishing the setup for it.
I'm just waiting on the team behind the server to like finish setting up their end.
So like, I have everything set up on my end for the Discord server for the Minecraft server to do the whitelist stuff.
But like, I'm just waiting on them to finish setting everything up now.
So, um, I finished all my part of the thing.
Um, because a couple days ago, I was free for a bit.
This was before the tournament.
I was free.
I had free time.
And also, like, my manager was like, God, get through your to-do list.
And then like, cause I felt a lot better.
I wasn't like as sick that day.
So I went through my to-do list.
So I just did the things I had to do to finish my side of setting it up.
So now I'm just waiting on them.
Um, I'm just waiting on them to finish their end.
Finishing the setup for the Discord server and everything.
So, um, I don't know when exactly it'll be.
Cause I could message them again today and they'd be like, Oh, guys, when will I, when?
Cause like, we have the server all, all like, finalized.
Regarding like, my side of setting it up for the Discord server.
So I'm just waiting on them.
Um, um, and everything.
Um, no, we're keeping the Minecraft server, but we will update it.
We're gonna update it, but only when your newly explored areas will have the newer Minecraft stuff.
Um, cause I know like, there's new Minecraft stuff now.
Anyway, you know what I realized?
There's a lot of Sanrio boxers.
Like, surprisingly, I was not expecting that.
Like, I, there's like, I don't know why, but there's a huge market for like, official Sanrio boxers.
Which was very surprising to me, because you know, Sanrio is like, the ladies, oh, that is true.
But like, I don't know.
Cause Sanrio, you know, Sanrio is like, more catered towards like, like, women, you know?
Um, men can be, that's true, men can be cute too.
But like, I, I just thought it was like, really funny.
You know, like, you wear this on your first date.
What if you wear this on your first date, guys?
Would you wear this on your first date?
Would you, would you wear this on your first date?
You're right, you're right, you're right.
Twinks do, do exist.
You're right.
She's not seeing it anyway, so, but what if she will?
She'll like it.
No, you're right, you're right, she'll enjoy it.
She'll be like, oh my god, he's the one, you should always wear this up.
You're right, guys.
Who am I kidding?
You should always wear this on your first date.
Cause if it, if you're about to hit a home run, she would appreciate this.
This is like flirting, um, how to riz with Doki.
As a woman.
Here's my cheat code for you men out there, and women too.
Wear this on your first date.
Because, if you do make it, and then, you know, you're about to, you know, you take off your pants, and she sees this.
Or he sees this, you're in, you're so in.
And if it doesn't work, it only works one out of five times.
So I'm, I mean, four out of, it only works four out of five times.
So I'm really sorry, you were just the one person that didn't work with, you know.
Probability wise, you just weren't that, you just hit the unlucky street.
But four out of five times it works, guys.
You were just the fifth guy that didn't work.
No, no, no, no.
You were all just the fifth guy where it doesn't work.
It's like the naked man in How I Met Your Mother.
It works four out of five times.
Because you're just the fifth person where it doesn't work.
You lost the pity, exactly.
Um, Yabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, you can't even play HuniePop, not taking Risley.
Okay, that's different!
That's anime women!
That's different!
Alright?
That's anime women.
My advice works for fleshies, okay?
I don't have good wrists for 2D, but I have really good wrists for 3D, so...
Like, did you see her?
Did you see the proportions?
Look.
You are...
That's why!
You're only good at...
Okay, I don't even know this.
The people who are not part of the same dimensions tend to be good...
Like, okay.
So it's like...
Okay, here's how...
This is like the metaphor.
This is like comparison.
Like, you trust vets, right?
You trust vets.
But they're not animals.
They're not dogs.
But you trust a vet with your dog's life.
Why the fuck would you trust a human person being for your dog's life when they're not even a dog themselves?
They don't know what they're saying.
How do you know what they're doing is right?
But you trust them.
There.
You trust them, right?
So it's just like me.
I might be an anime woman, but like, you should be able to trust me to give you advice regarding fleshies.
I might not be fleshy, but I can still give good advice.
They're trained by other people.
By other people.
They're being trained by other people.
They're not being trained by another fucking dog.
They're not being trained by a fucking cat.
They're trained by other people.
So like, how do you know what they say is correct?
Exactly.
Where's your fleshy license?
And the gold medal in mental gymnastics goes to Toe Keeper.
Thank you for the magenta suit, bud.
Thank you, thank you.
Doctors have actual research experience.
Yeah, for human beings.
How do you know the vet knows what they're doing?
They're trained by other people.
It's not like...
It's like...
But you still trust them.
You still trust them.
They're served by humans.
They're served...
It's not like the dog fucking gave that person a diploma.
Be like, great job.
You know exactly what's going on inside me.
We don't know that.
See, look at that.
Checkmate, guys.
Get lawyered.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I might be a vegan, but I know my meat's hot turkey right now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There you go.
Exactly.
I know.
You don't know that.
Have you asked that?
Show us your diploma.
Diplomas are fake.
They're fake news.
Anyone can buy a diploma.
I'm here for real life experiences, guys.
I'm here to provide life experiences.
From what I experience.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If the Hello Kitty boxers didn't work, she wasn't the right...
Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
She just wasn't the right one.
Didn't you go to college?
Exactly.
And now I'm here being an anime girl.
Fucking giving you life advice.
You think my diploma meant anything?
That you're just proving my point.
You're fucking proving my point.
What I do for a living...
Is...
I did not need to go to school for.
All I needed was Twitter.
To do what I do.
Which is a little sad.
I get my news updates on Twitter.
Is there actually boxer briefs?
Wait, are these boxers?
I don't know my boxers and briefs.
Okay, boxers.
What the fuck is the difference between boxers and boxer briefs?
Oh, okay.
I guess I'll do boxer briefs and boxers then.
But no briefs.
No briefs.
Just boxers and boxer briefs.
Bro, you think I know?
Bro!
You think I fucking know the difference between boxers and...
What if this guy was just wearing a really small boxers?
You guys don't know that?
Okay, this is gonna be my...
Alright, guys.
Would it be...
Okay, guys, let me draw this.
Would it be fucked up if I make this my boxer...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I want one of them to be boxer briefs.
But would it be fucked up if I made this one of my boxer brief designs?
Where it's like...
So cute.
Why are you laughing?
I'm not laughing.
I'm just...
I'm just trying to figure out what the design will be.
And I have a really good idea on what I want my design to be.
Okay, so...
Wait, how do I...
Boost up the...
Okay, how do I make the...
Oh, here's the paint size.
There we go.
Okay, so that...
It's gonna look like this.
So, like, this is like where...
You guys will know.
This is exactly where the...
Okay, so...
This is gonna be the design.
So, the mouth is...
So...
So you guys will know where the mouth is gonna be.
But like, you know...
You got a lady over...
And then you show them this.
And then the mouth is where...
The fun is.
That's the best.
There ain't no way.
It's kinda too...
You need to be stopped.
So it'll be the...
It'll be the tomato...
It'll be the tomato boxer briefs.
So, I think if I'm gonna make boxer briefs...
It's gonna be the tomato one.
And...
No, don't.
Please, don't.
Oh, my God.
I just realized what I meant by that.
I just...
I just realized.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, but...
I'm not backing down, though.
I'm...
Now I just need to release.
Okay, you're right.
It should be a little high.
You're right, guys.
The mouth should be...
You're right.
I'll put it right here.
It would look better if the mouth was like...
It would look better position-wise.
Is that better?
Position-wise.
You're right.
The mouth should be a little higher.
How would you resist?
Thank you for the super chat wings.
Thank you, thank you.
There we go.
This is my next merch idea.
I wanna make it so that...
The design is hilarious.
I'll buy it.
So it'll be the tomato.
Okay, so let me...
Let me color it, too.
Guys...
Oh, my God.
Let me color it, too.
Guys, you're right.
I should color it.
So you guys can be more immersed.
Alright, so...
So it'll be red, as you guys all know.
It'll be red.
So it'll be like this.
And then I'm gonna make sure to color this part green.
And then everything else would be...
Alright, so this is how...
How the boxers would look like.
Right here.
We colorize it.
There we go.
I think it's perfect!
I'm not even kidding.
And it doesn't even look like VTuber merch.
It just looks like...
It doesn't even look like VTuber merch at all.
It's just...
Anybody can wear it.
I'll make it in all sizes.
For everyone.
It's beautiful.
Full Technicolor.
I don't... What do you mean you don't like this anymore?
This is like a million dollar merch idea.
It's like...
I swear, if I propose this at Shark Tank...
I'd get all the funding, guys.
This is a Shark Tank product.
100%.
My wife will be getting a nice surprise on our next date night.
Jason, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Hey, baby.
I want to see my Doki Bird collection.
No, you'd be like...
Oh my god.
You'd be like, hey, babe.
I just got a new Doki Bird package.
You want to check the package out?
No!
It's just the wrist.
What do you mean?
A million dollar idea right here.
Zero, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Send the screenshot to my boyfriend and prove this.
Tomato boxes for date is a go.
Buttass who has two faces.
Please.
Fireball, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Spencer.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is the front, by the way.
By the way, guys, this is the front design.
By the way.
This is...
This is not the back design of the boxer briefs.
This is absolutely the front design.
That's why...
That's why I have to move the mouth somewhere.
What's the back?
Oh, that's a good question.
I don't know what to put on the back.
I don't know.
You're right.
What do I put on the back of it?
I don't know.
Maybe I should just...
Should I just put, like...
Oh, I should put, like, a tomato...
A fake butt.
X marks the spot.
There's an X on the tomato?
The bottom.
Oh, man.
I'll figure that out later.
I just know what...
You see, this is, like...
This is exactly why I have my repentance...
Pan here.
This is exactly why... On Ash Wednesday, too.
Ash Wednesday.
The perfect day to repent.
Alright.
Thank you, guys.
I'm glad, like, you all think it's a really good idea.
I was thinking about a new merch idea and I'm definitely gonna...
I'm definitely gonna do something like that.
I was thinking about it, too.
I was like, man, I really...
Anything.
I want... Just, like...
The back is an exit sign.
Mori, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um... I just thought it was a really neat idea, you know?
Cause, like, I owned my Melody Boxer briefs and I was like, oh, man, I wanna make something similar.
But, like, I wanted the face to be the front instead of the back.
Cause, like...
Cause you know why.
You know why.
John, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
I showed you my Toki boat.
Please, please respond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why do I see it?
Oh, this is my inspiration.
This is my inspiration for, like, new merch ideas.
Um... Yeah, I know!
These boxes look so sick.
Thank you, Hello Kitty.
Um...
Kongo, thank you for the super chat.
I'm all here up, uh, experimenting, you know?
I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm a fucking entrepreneur.
What can I say?
I have great ideas.
Um, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, yeah.
I'm not okay.
I'm not okay, guys.
Uh, Scrooge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The back just has a little X for the butt.
Oh, it's like Pompompurin.
Where, like, his butthole, his bootyhole is just like a little X on it.
Oh my god.
I mean, it could be, yeah.
See, look at that.
There's no bad ideas.
Just...
Just ideas that haven't yet been discovered, guys.
Like I said, there's no bad ideas, everybody.
Okay?
Can we also get a Doge or Penis Bowl merch to send to our local churches?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, yeah.
Ah, I'm so tired.
I'm glad I was able to hang out with you guys, though.
I really wanted to just, like, chill today and just talk to you guys and everything.
Um, yeah.
I just feel really lazy.
I feel really lazy.
I didn't want to, like...
I didn't want to scream or yell today.
Cause, like, that's usually what happens when I'm gaming.
So I just wanted to, like, take it easy and, um, hang out with all of you guys.
What's your plans for tomorrow's stream?
I don't know.
Most likely a gaming stream tomorrow.
Um, I'll do, like, a game that's, like... I'll do something like a one-off, maybe, tomorrow.
Like, usually at 5pm or something.
Um, but I'll do something one-off tomorrow.
If not, maybe I'll...
No, I'll just do, like, an actual stream.
Uh, so...
Maybe I'll do the digging holes one.
Yeah, I haven't done the hole dig yet, but I was thinking about the digging one, but then I was like, uh, is this gonna be a chatting stream?
Most likely.
So I wanna do something else.
I wanna play something.
I wanna play a game.
There was, like, one where you could make a museum.
There's, like, a museum game.
Oh!
I saw someone link me, like, how to play Battle for Middle Earth, like, on PC.
Cause there's, like, modders that, like, made, like, the RTS.
Like, I'd be down to play that, too.
Cause it's, like, one of my favorite RTS games.
So, let's... I'll just see how...
I'll see if I can figure it out.
Um, and, like, figure out if I can actually... if I can actually get it working.
Cause if I can, maybe I'll do that tomorrow.
Cause I really wanna... I've been craving to play Battle for Middle Earth for a long time.
So, yeah.
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
Uh...
Uh, but yeah, I have no ideas yet.
Literally, I've just been, like, incredibly lazy.
I've been so fucking lazy.
So, I have, like, zero plans on my week.
I...
Most of the time, I've just been, like, like I said, just doing nothing.
Which is bad, because I should be productive, cause I have a lot of stuff to do.
But, like, um...
Um...
But, like, I have an excuse just because of the Marble Rivals tournament I had earlier.
And I won first place!
So, I was, like, I'm treating myself.
I'm treating myself to, like, chill.
Uh...
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
...
Alright, guys, I did say today was gonna be a short stream.
Um, so, I am gonna chill now.
I'm gonna chill now.
I had a great time hanging out with all of you guys.
Oh, it's your birthday, too?
Let's do a birthday song before we go.
Another birthday song.
Madelyn, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Vaseline.
Yeah, happy birthday!
So, I'm sorry this was a really short stream.
I just wanted... like I said...
I'm feeling like... I'm feeling like particularly eepy and lazy.
But I had a great time talking with all my Dragons.
I always have a great time hanging out with you guys.
And I think like, I've sinned enough today.
Today, I have sinned enough.
So I feel like it might be a good time to call it before I dig myself a deeper hole.
But anyway guys, it was great to hang out.
I hope you guys enjoyed...
Um... enjoyed the, um...
The gorilla stream today.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me...
Head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll most likely...
Post a schedule later tonight.
I'll finish it up.
Somehow... I will finish it up.
I will.
I'll post a schedule later tonight to figure out what exactly I want to do.
Anyway, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!